Tụi từng Israel Benjamin này tà dầu hú cạnh báo sẽ tiếp tục các cuộc tần công,
giằm bỏ lỗ lượng hú thí sau các cuộc không việc vào các địa diện của lượng này.
Ê, Yemen, Hinh Chen, một trong năm 2020.
Đúng thời ông này tà dù hương hàng địch, bật cứ ảnh tấn công và Israel đều sẽ bị đánh bài.
Còn lỗ Israel cũng ngay cho biết cuộc không việc giằm bỏ lỗ sản à của Yemen,
là đậm thái đáp trả của cuộc tần công gần đây, zò lỗ lượng hú phía thực hiện,
nhà bỏ lãnh Thổ Israel trong đó có việc phòng thiết bài khung người lãi và tên lượng đất đối đất.
Trong số các cuộc tần công, rang chui có vụ hú thí xử dụt thiết bài khung người lãi,
tấn công sân vai ramom, mà nạm Israel, vụ việc đà khiến không phận khu vực bị đón cửa tạm thời và một số hành khách bị thương, zò, chú mạnh bởi.
Pê tần mình, hú xí cho biết các cuộc tần công của Israel ngủ hình chiến,
nhà bỏ các địa diện của lượng này tại Yemen đã làm ý chết bà mấy lòng người th mà bà mấy mốt người bị thương.
Trong khi đó, liên quan tình hình gaza, lưu lượng phòng vị Israel i đe F ngờ một mỗi thành chiến thông báo,
sẽ tăng tất các cuộc công quyết tại thành phố gaza Cd, trong ngày tới với mục tiêu phá huy của sửa tần của không trọng hửa hà mắt.
Trước đó, hôm mình chỉ ngä chiến i đe F đã đưa ra lệnh sơ đàn lớn nhất từ chuyện lĩnh này,
của tôi được gửi cư dân thành phố này.